[Music]
only a few months ago the term nft was
exploding all over the internet now to
the latest trend the skyrocketing prices
for digital arts sold as nfts the
christie's auction for digital artist
beeple coming to a close a few moments
ago the final bid 69 million dollars 69
million dollars i think it probably
means digital art is here to stay
anybody in this sector has to admit that
they were shocked by the size and the
ferocity and speed that the industry
evolved so quickly the number of wallets
that were purchasing nfts skyrocketed
the number of transactions of nfts
across the board skyrocketed and the
prices for many nft artists also went up
but that came down very very fast once
red hot nfts are now cooling off a bit
the secondary market for the majority of
people's paintings today is down 90 95
from the peak as is most nft art
but even more recently nfts have been on
the rise once again
and even with significant value
volatility in nft artwork nft
collectibles like nba top shot and nft
based video games like axi infinity have
surged in popularity the correction that
kind of happened with the nft art side
is healthy and what we're going to see
come out of that now are projects that
actually have utility that'll be able to
affect a much wider amount of people i
think that's where the excitement is and
many companies are betting that nfts
will enter the video game world in a big
way which if successful could open nfts
to a massive new audience and forever
change the way we value digital objects
we are in the process of an exodus from
the physical world to these digital
worlds that have been created over the
last 20 years and that continue to be
created and where people are spending an
increasing amount of their conscious
time
[Music]
you may have heard by now that nft
stands for non-fungible token
but explaining exactly what that means
can get complicated
so for our purposes what you need to
know is that through blockchain
technology digital objects like a jpeg
file or a virtual sneaker or even a meme
that you'd normally think about as being
infinitely reproducible can now be made
scarce
so for example if you're resourceful the
video you're watching right now could be
downloaded from youtube and you could
copy and paste it as much as you'd like
in theory it is infinitely reproducible
tokenizing or minting is the process you
can go through via blockchain where you
can create a record of scarcity
in the blockchain you can enter into a
ledger that there are only a thousand
versions of this video or a hundred or
even just one
taking something that was infinitely
replicatable and giving it artificial
scarcity and if you're rushing out to
try and download this video now thinking
you'll make a quick buck that's not
exactly how it works only the holder of
the nft in what are known as digital
wallets can actually own the item and
they can choose to resell them in
exchange for cryptocurrencies
but while we have seen some high sale
prices are buying these nfts actually a
good investment i would hesitate to call
nfts an asset class they are an asset in
the same way that i would hesitate to
call art an asset class art is an asset
but
for it to be an asset class it really
needs to be something that you can
buy and sell and buy and sell
this is bloomberg's art reporter james
tarmy so all you have to do when you
think about the art market and you think
about the prices that are paid for these
10 million dollar paintings 20 million
paintings 30 million paintings is think
about what kind of liquidity you need to
have to spend 30 million dollars on
something that you cannot resell anytime
soon so
there is not a line of people waiting to
spend 30 million dollars on the painting
that you just bought there might be one
other person or maybe two other people
but that's no guarantee that those two
other people want to buy that painting
when you want to sell that painting
and this is similar in the nft space
the number of people able to spend large
sums of cryptocurrency on nfts is
relatively small
and a lot of people became very
interested in jumping on the bandwagon
there was a world that was opened up
to
a general public that they didn't know
about and that seemed like
a world of infinite possibilities
and so
corporations suddenly started releasing
nfts
charmin toilet paper released in ft i
just got an email about campbell's soups
first nft and this isn't just about
artworks this is also about the various
nfts that are connected to games and
virtual worlds and so forth people are
connecting houses to nfts they're
connecting physical artworks to nfts
they're connecting portions of an entire
soccer team in a mexican soccer league
to nfts and then something weird started
to happen right more people were making
nfts than buying nft so you had
a lot of people trying to jump on a
bandwagon
that
might not really have existed in the
first place
and while the initial boom of interest
did drive more people to participate in
the nft marketplace than before
[Music]
those numbers are still relatively small
according to a 2021 report by
nonfungible.com
weekly active wallets in theory the
number of people who bought and sold
nfts in a given week peaked at only
forty thousand
and if nfts are going to become the
asset class of the digital future the
number of buyers and sellers in the
market must increase by a lot there's
still a tremendous amount of friction
to get a metamask wallet to understand
the idea of holding private keys to
engage with this world it's um
it's a process
this is sam engelbart he's the general
partner at a venture business called
galaxy interactive they currently manage
a 500 million dollar fund investing in
technology and content aimed towards the
future of digital worlds i spend a lot
of time
these days um first trying to just
define what the metaverse is uh and and
then make sure we're all talking about
the same thing because i think we're
still quite a ways away from
an immersive world like ready player one
being something that we all inhabit
except for eating sleeping and bathroom
breaks whatever people want to do they
do it in the oasis i think we are very
very close and witnessing every day
though the exodus from a purely physical
world to an increasingly
immersive synthetic digital world that
doesn't look like one place we all go to
but is actually just the amalgamation of
uh of of the different digital worlds
that we experience on our various
devices
and a lot of players are investing in
this future digital world
a recent bloomberg intelligence report
believes that the market opportunity for
the metaverse could be 800 billion
dollars by 2024 and for galaxy
interactive one of their biggest
investments has been in gaming i don't
believe
um
long term that just by making something
an nft it's gonna be interesting enough
to be all that meaningful unless you
build some sort of a game or metagame
into the process of collecting itself
merging nfts with games has already seen
some great success
one of the earliest breakout nfts was
cryptokitties
cartoon cats that users can buy sell and
even breed
the nft became so popular at one point
that it clogged the entire ethereum
network back in 2017 and it continues to
have an active community today
and one of the drivers of increased
digital wallets post the nft boom in
early 2021 has been a game called axi
infinity
these pokemon-like creatures are all
unique nfts that a user can buy into and
level up by playing in a new business
model known as play to earn what could
be better than a free game well how
about a game that pays you to play it
so far it's allowed people in developing
economies like the philippines in
vietnam to earn real money through
playing
and now a team of veteran video game
developers at mythical games are working
on their first nft based game blancos
block party with real toys in real life
the way to keep their value is you put
them in the box you put them on the
shelf you leave them there but with
blancos as you play with them
they get better
most games if you bought a spider-man
character or you bought a league of
legends skin they're virtual items they
stay within that ecosystem once you buy
them you bought them right there's
there's nothing else you could really do
with them at that point and what we're
doing in the kind of experimentation
with blancos is players own them they
can sell these assets they can level
them up and mash them up to create new
ones and all that so it really gives the
players a lot of freedom to uh to build
play and earn this is mythical games ceo
john linden he sees games as a great
means to introduce more people into the
nft and crypto world so one of the goals
at mythical was we really wanted to
bring this concept of blockchain and nft
assets to the mainstream gamer right so
maybe someone that doesn't fully
understand crypto and is not you know an
investor in ethereum we really wanted to
make sure that they could partake in
this economy
and his success in this space isn't
necessarily about having big headline
grabbing single asset sales but rather
having a much larger volume of sales
overall we're not thinking about it in
terms of a 10 item that's worth a
million dollars the next day we're
thinking about it in terms of a 10 item
that becomes worth 25 and a 25 item that
becomes worth 40 and a 40 item becomes
worth 75 and those are still if you
think about those are amazing they don't
sound sexy but they're amazing returns
on on investments right so so we're
definitely thinking about it in terms of
something that's attainable something
that the average consumer can actually
partake in latest trades 55
20
not not kind of a new fine art to where
only a very few select people can
actually see that appreciation because
the numbers are just so ridiculous that
you can't can't participate
but growing a market for nfts currently
can come at some pretty large costs
each transaction requires a ton of
energy from computers all around the
world potentially resulting in increased
carbon emissions and although the
ethereum network is hard at work to
reduce its overall energy consumption it
does remain to this day too high to
support a scaled version of this model
what we're starting to see
technologically now is
the need to to
advance the underlying tech so that you
can have a business
around the purchase and sale and trading
of objects that are one dollar five
dollars twenty dollars fifty dollars
that's partly why mythical games is
using their own blockchain technology
within their mythical economic engine
but it's also because they believe that
creating and selling an nft game engine
will help create more nft games in the
future what we set out to do at the very
beginning was to build this economic
engine to where we could ultimately have
a lot of the top games in the world be
able to access this type of technology
have the regulatory side covered have
access to marketplace tech things that
normal game studios wouldn't be building
themselves
we think that this type of economy will
really permeate through every game type
and honestly i can see almost every
every game out there could have some
version of this
but building the technology is only the
first step to building value
gaming also offers another important
step in this process
community blockchain doesn't make a game
better we kind of joke here that if your
game sucks without blockchain it's gonna
suck with blockchain right
what makes this technology powerful and
interesting is the ability to ignite a
community and if you build the right
community then the things you own
digital objects in a lot of cases
will be valuable within that community
and people are going to want to own them
and they're going to want to trade them
amongst each other we've seen an amazing
community forum around blanca's and even
before the game came out we had about a
million dollars in blanco sold because
players saw that value and they
collaborated with each other and we're
excited by the outcome of where that
could go
[Music]
for someone outside of the blankos
community it might seem outrageous to
spend five thousand dollars on a virtual
doll
just like for many it's outrageous to
spend 69 million dollars on this
people's piece
or for spending 120 000 on a banana duct
taped to a wall
value
for things that have no use value is
entirely the result of perception
a picasso is just oil paint on canvas
it's worth nothing it does nothing
it is valuable because we as a society
have decided that it's valuable
could nfts become a brief weird piece of
history
absolutely
could they become an integral part of
the way that we engage with each other
and companies online absolutely
[Music]
you